good evening and welcome to that guy
riffs today
Noah ant wire joins the riff as they
look at what happens when party
etiquette is told by the spawns of Satan
sit back and enjoy approved by Sam the
Eagle Cindy goes to a party and gets
crunk
well this is a much more pleasant
follow-up to their last movie Cindy gets
violent bowel surgery center on the
company that makes videos showing you
how to behave at a party and how to deal
with the STD you get at the party come
on okay mom clearly in a studio tomorrow
I'm going to Mary's party tomorrow
aren't you
a party why I didn't even dot dot dot no
I don't like parties I never have any
fun at parties I was kind of hoping you
go parties are more fun and all your
friends are there well I'd better go
I'll hear my mom calling and step-
prettiest of a merry look goddamn Rio
just don't know Mitchell sure don't
clear this lip Lana this is an
interesting prequel to carry the end
mother why do you suppose Mary didn't
invite me to her party
well said you could talk you didn't get
an invitation maybe they don't even want
to go to a party they probably thought I
would know how to add hey no no booka
you will get an invitation to the party
you just been some mix-up mom is a racer
head oh it's not important to hell good
night mother
good night Cindy I'm off to drunk-dial
your father to see why he hasn't taken
you yet
your name's Cindy not Cinderella you go
to the park kill your parents
mace and pay shock therapy they float
right all float me in me wake up Fendi
it's your other personality who's there
I don't see anybody I'm not just anybody
I'm your fairy godmother from hell
here you don't believe me shall I show
you a demonstration of my evil powers I
just thought you might want to go to
that party oh I do I do
we've got some work to do we've gotta
get you ready oh but I wasn't invited to
the party they probably thought I'd
better play basketball or go fishing or
well you've been invited all right
I think of it I'm a very crawl let him
tell anyone not even Dennis well maybe
we'd better tell Dennis whoever that is
feeling he'd going to need my help to
hurry up or you'll be late
the party isn't until this afternoon
Satan my Dark Lord I command thee it is
effective hurry up runnin whoa what a
man you need rubber sheets that's why I
have the magic wand
ready the devil transformed us oh but
this isn't my very best dress it's not
slutty enough you're not going to the
party to show off your clothes but you
should be me and meet when you go to the
party you are a god hurry now we don't
want to be late
ready here we go - Mary don't be nosy
dog reducir we are oh I hope everyone is
already here I'd hate to be the first
one I don't blame you
no one likes to sit and wait for a party
to start the party can't really get
going until everyone around bringing
their pipes whenever you go to a party
Cyndi always go for time
on time and when the clock says it's
time to go home
father we summon sure to leave on time
that's important for my culture like
Cinderella what do you know but you can
yes a mirrors Bjork looking creepier
yeah so that everyone gets tired and
bored
come on oh look here comes to the other
side don't know one of my presence cool
i Cindy who are you talking to
oh no I was just thinking out loud I
guess hi Janet Cindy
oh hey Dennis invited you you weren't
coming to the party I'm worth it but
you'll see then you'll understand see
you see who by the 7 tails of Cerberus
we transport be me ah someone spiked the
punch bowl again why you've gotta help
us enjoy the party you are Oh
see they're setting up for a game of
musical chairs
ah but I don't watch mortal you will
participate that's the way to have fun
at a party isn't it join in the game a
party calls for teamwork nobody will
have any fun unless everyone joins in so
join in who heartedly and any game
suggested and you'll have a lot more fun
I'll be watching you from afar just do
what she says question anything we're
having fun
that's 20 minutes in the Cerberus pit
hmm
remember now the blood of virgins makes
me strong oh I mean that don't be too
noisy or rough and don't break things
chief banks yeah you lost your chair -
you're out of the game
go home for bumping into things oh she's
only kidding I know but she obsessed
with the written word watch I never do
not even your very best friend they
might not understand being funny is
cancerous serious their feelings would
be hurt and then neither of you would
have any fun now would all right guy God
never all the music starting what do I
do
well I don't what you have been doing
sit in the corner and shut up obey the
rules of the game hey next life please
be a good new here hi get away from me
I never understood why they took musical
chairs of the Olympics they got golf of
Mary I watch
oh you read me it's a tie hey that was
fun actually you want ah
sure she did but here Cindy you showing
what I whispered and read just as I sat
down and chair she said cross me or die
be a good winner
and she would see how much fun it is
when you join in the games in the right
way I just hope I can remember the right
ways you've shown us that's easy just
remember your manners oh she's the
fucking PowerPoint fairy the whole be
considerate of other so have fun
together what game is this bull the
potato across the room your time is
running out children oh and now they're
playing pointed market people this was
Cindy's last known photo today I only
brought two plates would you stop that's
wait a minute don't write anything
please merciless god I bet I know what
you're going to tell us remember our
table manners when eating now you spoil
my fun I wanted to write it for you
you'll have to die how you won't think
I've been any help to you oh you've been
a big help fairy godmother I've enjoyed
the party so go ahead and write it for
us if you want to sure we want you to
write for us don't patronize me little
snots
remember your table men you didn't
really need my help
you knew it already I guess you don't
need me anymore I must perform seven
years we'll be going oh no oh yeah you
can't see your fairies unless you need
them and you don't need me anymore
I guess the world just doesn't need
party etiquette fairies believe on time
won't you and you'll remember oh Jesus
is this movie made for the
hearing-impaired any more parties will
remember to be clean and neat and
beyond time and will be considerate of
others to will join in the game just
don't hurt us the real and make fun for
everybody not fun of anybody or be too
noisy or too rough and we'll remember
our table manners when eating and if the
cops show up remember to flush the
evidence good parties are fun when
everyone is considerate of other good
bye now gilberto don't go don't go don't
go don't go Shan Shan come back Shane
Shane Oh Oh mother I just dream that
never once
Cindy here's Mary sister Nancy she just
came by to tell you that she was
supposed to deliver your invitation to
Mary's party three days ago but he
forgot she was drunk at night sorry to
come by so early this morning to tell
you about it oh yes oh thank you thank
you so much instead of saying you're
welcome allow me to just stare creepily
at you remember parties are about rules
and conformity not having fun and being
yourself you see a party etiquette vary
notify your local priest